we're gonna go to the El Paso shooting
changing topics now to put racism and
racial issues back at the center of the
political debate here in America a Pew
Research poll finds more than half of
American adults think race relations are
bad and getting worse
now professor Abram Ken D is on a
mission to set the country on a new path
toward equality in his new book how to
be an anti-racist Kenny calls racism a
cancer and explains how readers can
shift their thinking to stop it earlier
we just saw him speak with 12 community
members about the issue on the second
anniversary of the Charlottesville
attack they were there Kennedy is the
founding director of the anti-racist
research and Policy Center at American
University and joins us at the table
good to have you back professor pleasure
to be on all right doctors start with
this because you said being an
anti-racist is not the same as being not
racist and I was very confused I had to
read that page a couple times so explain
exactly what you mean in in simple terms
the simplest way to understand it is
when we think of the history of the term
not racist yeah we're really thinking
about eugenicist when being charged with
being racist saying they're not racist
we're thinking about Jim Crow
segregation ax staying they're not
racist white nationalists and
supremacists today say they're not
racist and so we're really taking about
a term in which people are denying that
they are racist that's really the only
meaning real meaning that this term is
as hell but anti-racist
in in contrast has a meaning a meaning
of somebody who views the racial groups
as equals someone who is pressing for
policies that creates racial equity and
that's the key to look at racial equity
because I remember when the El Paso
shooting happened I don't know any black
person in this country when they first
heard it that said oh lord please don't
let him be black and you write about
this in your book that why do we take on
that mantle because that's not something
white people think when there's a
shooting because I think in many ways
what what what what idea is with what
our racial discussion has done is it's
caused individuals particularly black
individuals to carry the mantle of race
the whole race yes partly because we
know that when people see a lazy black
person they're just not seeing a lazy
person they're seeing lazy black people
they're generalizing this individual
negativity as opposed to allowing in
to be individuals you write that you
used to be a racist most of the time but
you're now on a mission to be
anti-racist but how did you recognize
this and and how did you change and most
people think black people can't be
racist either by the way well I mean I
grew up in the 80s and the 90s a time in
which young black males were classified
like me who were classified as super
predators a time when young black girls
were thought to be hyper sexual having
all these babies we were our communities
were imagined to be severely dangerous
these were racist ideas circulating not
only among white people even among black
people and young people like me were
internalizing these ideas internalizing
thinking that the problem was in part
black people and I thought that for long
you believed that I thought it yeah I
believed it until I realized that there
was nothing the only thing wrong with
black people is that we thought
something was wrong with black people
yeah and that the fundamental racial
problem was racist policy one of the
interesting things in the book is the
idea that being a racist is not an
identity it is not a permanent condition
of an individual it's a temporary
condition based on actions why define it
in that way because I think with my
earlier work chronicling the history of
racist ideas I found that you had some
people who in the same speech even in
the same paragraph of the same speech
would say things that were both racist
and anti-racist they would speak at the
same time right so then how would we
identify that person as being a racist
when they also said anti-racist things
they also spoke about racial equality
and so what's actually happening is I
define racist and even anti-racist as
based on what a person is saying or
doing in the moment and we constantly
change human beings are deeply complex
and I think that's a more accurate way
to explain you call racism a cancer and
that it should be treated like a cancer
and I know you don't say this lightly
because you've had stage 4 colon cancer
yeah and I've had stage 4 colon cancer
your wife is my wife had breast cancer
my my mother had had breast cancer even
my father had had cancer and and so I
think through experiencing my own cancer
as well as caretaking for loved ones
but cancer I've be able to see how
cancer is treated yeah in generally
particularly with metastatic cancer and
I had metastatic cancer and I would
argue we have metastatic racism in this
country there's typically a local
treatment in which you go in and
surgically remove the tumors which is
essentially like going in to remove the
racist policies or do you have your
health today can the country get its
health when it comes to metastatic
racism as you put it I think so
I think if we if we flood the body with
anti-racist policies if we believe in
the possibility that we can overcome
metastatic racism then I think we can
overcome how is your health today
you look good yeah I'm good I'm trying
to stay good thank you so much for being
with us this morning
welcome how to be an anti-racist goes on
sale tomorrow